more than 800 000 americans have died
from covid19 according to the
establishment media but
we know that some people who were
counted in that number did not actually
die
from
covid19 they merely died
with covid19 we have heard reports of
people dying in car accidents or even
gunshot wounds
being counted as having died from covid
because they tested positive in the
hospital before they succumbed to their
wounds we've heard reports of 90
something year olds with stage four
cancers counted as covid deaths because
they tested positive for the virus at
the time of their deaths so
to understand the true
death toll of covid
it seems reasonable to ask how many of
those 800 000
actually died from
covid but remember when some of us
raised this question months and months
and even over a year ago we were called
crazy radical conspiracy theorist
anti-science okay as of last week
rochelle wallenski the director of the
cdc
could not answer that question
how many of the 836 000 deaths in the
u.s linked to covid are from covid or
how many are with covet but they had
other co-morbidities do you have that
breakdown
um yes of course with omicron we're
following that very carefully our death
registry of course um takes a few weeks
to
and it takes a few weeks to collect and
of course omicron has just been with us
for a few weeks but those data will be
forthcoming
nothing has been forthcoming when it
comes to the cdc and coronavirus do you
see how she's spinning her wheels uh
well i don't know and you know we've got
we've got we've got the omicrons coming
in and so the data they lag but yeah
that's not what we're asking you lady
you've given us the 800 000 number how
many of those are actually from the
coronavirus and not just 97 year olds
with stage 4 pancreatic cancer who
happened to have covid when they died
you should know this answer you don't
need to wait several weeks for the
omicron data to come in
but we all know everyone lib and
conservative alike we all agree that the
official covid numbers have been at
least somewhat artificially inflated by
this problem so after buying time for a
day or two not for ten days not for two
weeks rachelle welinski has finally come
up with an answer
to just how inflated those numbers are
and just when you think the public
health establishment can't get any more
deceitful
wait until you hear this i'm michael
knowles it's the michael knowles show
[Music]
from
yesterday my absolute favorite comment
comes to us from take the clown pill who
says
we're not conspiracy theorists we're
spoiler alerts that's true
i should have said this at the top of
the show if you don't want to
hear the future don't tune into this
show close your ears right now if you
don't want to hear what will be on the
mainstream news networks in six to 12
months you really should tune out this
show if you if you want to just bide
your time let that excitement build and
then you're going to find out in six to
12 months what's actually going on right
now
then you should you should turn the show
off right now what could you do if you
did that well i guess you could uh you
could work on your family you could work
on your spirituality you could work on
your body
which is why i would recommend you check
out echelon i hate working out i'm not
telling any tales at a school i think
you know that to be true
i have not been to the gym
since the obama administration
there is one thing
that has gotten me not only to work out
but to enjoy working out
that would be
echelon echelon brings the gym home
when you're trying to reach your fitness
goals it can really help to have
world-class instructors choreographing
classes encouraging you music from your
favorite artists a community of hundreds
of thousands of people who can give you
that extra push echelon gives you all
that it's the affordable way to get the
workout equipment the workout community
and an instructor's motivation
right in the comfort of your own home
favorite part for me
i don't need to drive 20 minutes to the
gym get out get changed get on the gear
do the thing for whatever shower come
back 20 minutes you lose so much time
echelon you do it right in your own home
for a limited time our listeners will
get up to 650 off msrp
to get this exclusive podcast discount
text knowles canada wles to 81 81.81
that is knowles canon wles to 81 81 81
to get up to 650 off msrp k wlas 2
818181 message and data rates may apply
see terms for details
so director walensky 800 000 people were
we're told died of covid19 how many of
those are from covid19 how many of those
just happened to have had covid19 when
they died
the overwhelming number of deaths over
75 percent occurred in people who had at
least four comorbidities so really these
are people who were unwell to begin with
at least
four comorbidities
we also know that the median age of a
covid death
is north of
80. it it's higher than the life
expectancy
in this country
so
you're telling me
that three quarters of people who have
died from a virus that
tends to kill people who are already
above the average life expectancy
three-quarters of those people had at
least four other major
health problems
they were not well to begin with as
rachelle wolensky says
so then that 800 000 number i'm not
saying it's exactly 200 thousand i'm not
saying it's exactly one quarter of 800
000. obviously there's a lot of
ambiguity here and they're not being
particularly forthcoming with the
details
but it's a lot closer to that 200 000
number than we all thought when we're
talking about people who died explicitly
and directly
from
coronavirus that's a pretty big
difference factor of four wow
if you
if you had said this
six months ago a year ago
as some of us did you would have been
called a crazy anti-science
conspiracy theorist
now we're being told yeah maybe it's
closer to about two hundred thousand two
hundred thousand in two years
meaning a hundred thousand a year
meaning the same number of people who
died of drug overdoses last year
but we didn't we didn't shut the whole
world down because of drug overdoses
frankly maybe we should have we at least
should have shut the border down didn't
do that joe biden opened the border
right back up
that open border with fentanyl pouring
all across is killing just as many
people as coronavirus at least by the
most conservative numbers according to
rochelle wolinski the director of the
cdc
but drugs not a problem deaths of
despair suicide not a problem heart
disease not a big problem don't worry
about it we're not going to shut down
all the fast food companies
we're actually going to lock people in
their homes so they don't exercise that
i'm sure that'll that'll help them lose
weight right i'm sure that'll help them
get heart healthy no it's just this one
virus
that is the reason that we're going to
shut down the entire world completely
reorder society and make dr fauci king
of the universe
does that make a lot of sense well okay
we're only going to do that until
everyone's vaccinated everyone's got to
get vaccinated because the vaccines we
were originally told by joe biden by
rachelle wolenski director of the cdc
that the vaccines would stop infection
and stop transmission and then they
changed their tune on that because it
wasn't true but okay even though they're
not going to do that everyone's got to
get vaccinated we have a vaccine mandate
we actually have multiple vaccine
mandates coming out of the federal
government and then we can get back to
normal right you get your two shots
of of moderna or of pfizer or your one
shot of johnson johnson although there
have been some questions about that
vaccine there was that pause because of
blood clotting now there was a question
about the boosters for johnson johnson
says okay let's put that aside for now
you get your very simple you get your
two shots of pfizer you're fully
vaccinated we can get back to normal
right
except
that the ceo of pfizer is saying that
two shots of that vaccine what was
called fully vaccinated actually just
doesn't give you very much protection at
all
we know that um the three the two dose
of a vaccine offer very limited
protection if any the three doses with a
booster
they offer reasonable protection against
hospitalization and deaths
in again there's nothing very good
and
less protection against the infection
now
we are working on a new version of our
vaccine the 1.1 let me put it that way
that will cover omicron as well
and
of course
we are waiting to have the final results
the vaccine will be ready in march
so the vaccine for the virus that
everybody is getting right now
that i had a couple of weeks ago that
dozens of my friends and family members
have had over the past few weeks and
that i'm sure many dozens of your
friends and family members have had as
well they're going to get a vaccine for
that in march once everybody's had it
which is actually pretty brilliant by
the way
because if the vaccine comes out after
everyone already has antibodies from
getting the virus then there's no way to
prove it doesn't work
right pretty smart business decision
but furthermore before you censor me for
saying that the vaccine doesn't work i'm
just playing a clip of the ceo of pfizer
of the guy
who runs the company that that sells the
vaccine
and he says that the
what was called the full regime of
pfizer shots
offers very limited protection
if any at all
if any at all
which means there actually is a silver
lining to the storm cloud here
it means that the government's argument
for the vaccine mandate
just
completely fell apart
for two reasons one
the argument for the vaccine mandate
is
not even so much to protect you
as to protect other people from you
that's why the government's getting
involved
the government gives individuals a lot
of leeway to screw up their own lives
but where they draw the line is
particularly when it comes to public
health is when your decisions are
negatively affecting other people
so they say you don't have a right to go
infect other people during a pandemic
you you have their extraordinary police
powers during a pandemic and the
government can force you to get the
vaccine to protect other people
but we already know per
dr fauci per rochelle wolenski that the
vaccine does not prevent infection and
transmission they've already admitted
that
so
then the purpose of the mandate would
have to transform to be simply about
protecting you that's a an extraordinary
argument for the government to make we
haven't seen anything like that before
in american history
mandatory vaccines not to protect the
public but to protect you from your own
dumb decisions
but we just heard from the ceo of pfizer
that it won't even do that
the mandate as it stands right now says
you gotta get two shots of fives for two
shots of madonna one shot of johnson and
johnson
but the guys behind that now are saying
no that won't work that won't do
anything that will offer very limited
protection if any at all so what's going
to happen is osha going to change the
rule now and say actually you got to get
three shots actually you got to get two
johnson and johnson
that's not
that's that's not what the rule is right
now
so
what is the government's argument for
the mandate
it just feels like our country is
hurtling away from what we have been for
a long time
part of this is because we ship all of
our jobs overseas and we buy a lot of
our products from overseas well if you
want to support american ranchers right
here at home i'd strongly recommend you
check out good ranchers i really don't
like being lied to i feel that
we in this country have been lied to
much more than usual over the past
couple of years and and it drives me
crazy it's very
disrespectful to do that
did you know that your grocery stores
your your
meat suppliers are lying to you too
turns out that 85 percent of the
grass-fed beef in the united states is
imported from overseas even when you see
that sticker it says product of usa
that all that means is that the meat was
minimally processed here usually it's
coming from from ranchers overseas do
not buy cheap imported beef that lacks
true flavor go to goodranchers.com
knowles to cut through the
misinformation and get 100 american beef
delivered to your door today good
ranchers only sells beef that is born
raised and harvested in the united
states
they're 100 american steakhouse quality
all their steaks are usda prime and
choice grated
it means the steakhouse can come to you
in a good rancher's box of meat you get
rib eyes t-bones gourmet burgers
the burgers in particular are out of
this all the meat's great but the
burgers are out of this world plus you
can save 30 bucks with my code knowles
at checkout
that's 30 bucks off any box biggest
discount they've ever offered today is
the day to say big on your new favorite
steak they are the exclusive meat
company the daily wire for good reason
go to granters.com and i'll save 30
bucks make 2022 your most flavorful year
yet good ranchers
american meat delivered
even the white house cannot explain its
reasoning anymore on its virus and
vaccine policy i'm not sure the white
house ever could really explain it all
that well but but they would have
certain lines that would within their
own narrow context be at least
semi-coherent you need to get vaccinated
to protect the people from you
you need the vaccines are extremely
effective whatever you know at the at
the time these things seemed sort of
plausible
now they don't
peter ducey
one of the few reporters who asks
difficult questions at the white house
peter ducey came out and asked press
secretary jen sake hey jen
since
i'm vaxxed and i got kovid and you're
vaxxed and you got covid how come joe
biden is still calling this a pandemic
of the unvaccinated
i understand that the science says that
vaccines prevent
death
but
on triple backs still got coveted your
triple backs still got cobit
why is the president still referring to
this as a pandemic of the
unvaccinated well i think peter there's
a significant difference between and you
just you just experienced this and not
to expose your public health experience
but i can speak to mo mine as well i had
been triple vaxxed i had minor symptoms
there is a huge difference between that
and being unvaccinated you are 17 times
more likely to go to the hospital if
you're not vaccinated 20 times more
likely to die and those are significant
serious statistics so yes the impact uh
for people who are unvaccinated is far
more dire than those who are vaccinated
will the president update his language
at some time to be more reflective of
the fact that people who are triple
vaccinated are catching and spreading
covenant i think people president has
said as have we a number of times that
there will be breakthrough cases there
will be people who get covid uh here uh
at different media organizations at
companies around the world uh around the
country uh who have been vaccinated
how many millions of break breakthrough
cases do we need to have before we can
stop calling them breakthrough cases how
many do you think
i'm i'm thinking right now just off the
top of my head of all my friends and
family members who have gotten covered
some are vaccinated some are vaccinated
and boosted as some are not vaccinated
at all and won't go near the fauci algae
i guess the majority of my friends and
family who have gotten it have been
vaccinated
and some people had serious symptoms or
relatively you know by serious i mean
they were in bed for a couple days and
some people
really had very mild symptoms and there
was really no rhyme or reason
as to who had
which sort of severity of symptoms
between the unvaccinated the vaccinated
and the boosted
but furthermore speaking of symptoms do
you think gensake threw her back out
moving the goalposts like that i hope
she didn't i hope she's feeling better
but that must have been very strenuous
because peter ducey asked a very simple
question
since
people who have been vaccinated and
boosted
are contracting and spreading
coronavirus when is the president going
to stop calling it a pandemic of the
unvaccinated
and what did she say she said
well it's much worse for people who have
who are unvaccinated
but that's not the question we're
talking about the pandemic we're talking
about people who are contracting and
spreading a virus and the virus is
mutating and it's contagious and it's
spreading throughout the country
and that's happening happening with
vaccinated people as well as
unvaccinated people so why is joe biden
lying and saying that it's only
happening with unvaccinated people
she says well sure there are some
breakthrough cases no that's not what's
going on they're just everyone's getting
it lady everyone's getting this thing
well it's because omicron is is
different yeah okay yeah it's a variant
viruses have variants as they always do
and always will and always we're going
to
so why are you still pretending
that this is a virus that's only being
contracted and spread by people who are
unvaccinated well it's a lot worse if
you're okay so they have nothing so they
have absolutely nothing and they're
deflecting we'll get to that point later
by the way because i find it a little
dubious
but they're not just doing it on
coronavirus
i just filled up my gas tank
about an hour ago or less
it was
expensive more expensive than it has
been in a while i went to the grocery
store a few days ago
it was empty emptier than it was in
recent years prices are going
up and up and up
the economy is not in great shape
and yet if you look at the white house
twitter feed you will find out joe biden
is the greatest
jobs president
ever
this guy he's an economic genius must be
quote under president biden
the economy has created more jobs
per month than under any other president
ever
ever
and you can see on the graph you've got
you've got reagan there's little it goes
up a little bush one goes up a little
bit clinton goes up more george w bush
much lower
obama a little higher trump he's in the
negative he lost jobs he's bad i hate
him he's so he's so bad and then biden
wow big
yellow color all the way up through the
roof
a reminder
that there are lies
damned lies and statistics
the reason this comparison doesn't work
is
first of all because you're comparing
one year under joe biden to four and
eight-year terms
from trump to reagan
furthermore
when you're comparing biden to trump
you were comparing
a man whose presidency ended
during a global pandemic where the
government forced everyone to stop going
to work or forced a lot of people to
stop going to work so voluntarily put
people out of a job
to to a new administration where the
public health bureaucracy is now
encouraging the government to allow
people to go back to work so yes you're
gonna of course you're gonna see a
radical shift
it's it's as though you're you're
comparing someone's speed while driving
and for part of the comparison you do it
as they're screeching to a halt at a red
light and then for the next comparison
you're looking at what happens right
after the light turns green and the guy
floors it
uh sure i guess that'll tell you
something about those specific moments
but it's not going to tell you about
how fast the guy's actually going under
normal conditions over a longer haul
lies
damned lies
and statistics
speaking of people getting new jobs
clay aiken
clay aiken america's darling for a brief
period in the early 2000s the runner-up
on american idol clay aiken my
accidental nemesis
from politicon a few years ago clay
aiken is running for congress in north
carolina
he is running in north carolina's sixth
congressional district uh he's running
after he ran and lost in a different
district in north carolina's second
congressional district but i think he he
believes that he's got a better shot of
winning now in nc six
because of redistricting because it's a
very democrat district now
here is clay aiken's campaign
announcement
for decades north carolina was actually
the progressive beacon in the south we
had the best roads and the best schools
because
back then the loudest voices in our
government were progressives who
actually made sure our stay was always
moving forward
but then things changed and the
progressives lost power and we started
getting backwards ass policies like the
voter suppression bills and the bigoted
bathroom bill
because today it seems like the loudest
voices in north carolina politics are
white nationalists like this guy
my friends i encourage you
continue to make your voice heard
because
do we love donald trump
and hateful homophobes like this one
what is the purpose
of homosexuality what does it create
these folks are taking up all the oxygen
in the room and i'm gonna tell you i am
sick of it
and i'll tell you something else as
democrats we have got to get better
about speaking up and using our voices
because those folks ain't quieting down
anytime soon
that's why i'm running for congress and
just think how excited these guys are
going to be when we elect the south's
first gay congressman
so there are some republicans right now
who are friends with clay aiken
not naming any names but there are some
prominent republicans who are friends
with clay aiken who are excited that
he's running he's such a nice guy oh
he's sang that song i don't remember any
of his songs but he sang them nicely and
so isn't it clay aiken's a jerk he's a
freaking jerk and you got to beware the
nice guy in politics okay you got to be
oh i'm just come on i'm just playing i'm
just like come on y'all let's come on
let's come together so i was at
politicon a few years ago
and i was debating this guy chris hahn
who i had debated on fox news once and
so we were supposed to have this debate
me and chris hahn except we didn't end
up having a debate because clay aiken
was moderating and clay aiken took it
upon himself to be the actual opponent
in the debate so chris hahn was just
kind of pushed to the side and it was
just me and clay debating each other the
whole time our people who are marching
and shouting jews will not replace us
are they good people just a yes or no
question yes or no no it's a yes or no
question
are people who are marching shouting
jews will not replace nazis
can you say yes or no to this are you
capable of that i don't need to answer a
question because i'm not on the stage no
i did not ask you if nazis were bad and
i understand that those big fours real
people who are nazis are okay
that's not what i asked you i've
answered this five times
[Applause]
i asked a yes or no question
president trump lie yes or no before
before you before you start since since
clearly the audience thinks i'm biased
we're going to let them ask some
questions
well i may be a hack but i've got
[ __ ] microphone so um
and i just want to say clay you're
probably the worst moderator i've ever
seen in my life asking very dishonest
yes or no questions but anyways that's
perfectly fine clay aiken man he's like
a national trust i get food all the time
here i'm not worried about it
i'm not worried about it
you know stop it chris i'm
this guy's awful he's awful and he's got
this very disingenuous dated style of
politics well you know y'all um listen i
moved back here i got my voice but it i
don't know to me it reads like something
out of the late 90s or early 2000s
certainly pre-trump pre-social media
authentic politics i'm not sure it's
going to work just a reminder though i
mean the guy is calling a man a white
supremacist or white nationalist based
on absolutely nothing he says that
you're a hateful bigot if you think
dudes shouldn't go into the women's
bathroom and the only flag he flies in
his commercial is not the american flag
but the radical leftist lgbt elementop
flag this guy is awful he's a jerk
beware beware
the nice guys in
politics
if you have not
heard of jonathan isaac yet where have
you been have you been living under a
rock the nba star stood strong with his
values while everyone else kneeled and
faced heavy criticism from the media for
his views on social issues and vaccines
over the past few years which is why i'm
extremely excited to announce that he's
decided to write a book with the daily
wire called why i stand
jonathan's book will be about the rise
of his basketball career his journey
into faith and his strength to stand
alone in the face of immense pressure
check out this teaser
the orlando magic's 23 year old starting
forward is deeply religious and proudly
unvaccinated on friday isaac got
attention for choosing not to kneel in
unison with his teammates or to wear a
black lives matter shirt my name is
jonathan isaac i play for the orlando
magic and i'm writing a book with the
daily wire
[Music]
courage does not mean the absence of
fear and in today's day there are so
many things that you can be afraid of
facing because of believing what you
believe or deciding to stand for what
you believe in and i believe this book
gives you a blueprint of my story of how
christ has made the difference in my
life from a young kid who struggled with
fear anxiety
self-insecurity to a man willing to
stand for what he believes in
[Music]
i really like jonathan isaac i i was
chatting with him a few weeks ago i
guess he came by the office
and
it was the first time i've ever
spoken to someone who is i think 17 feet
tall and so it's i strained my neck to
talk to him but i kept straining it
because i so enjoyed it really really a
sincere guy and he's obviously got his
head screwed on straight and and his
heart is totally in the right place and
he's got the guts to actually stand up
for what he believes in jonathan's book
will be one of the first under the daily
wires new publishing arm dw books we
couldn't be happier to have him on board
the book isn't now available for
pre-order at amazon so reserve your copy
today we'll be right back with a lot
more
the left is so they're nice
like clay aiken they're really nice you
know smiley smiley they're really
they're responsible okay they're the
adults in the room
they're not insurrectionist terrorist
bigots like you
okay they're really they're mature
capable of self-government
the biden harris administration there
are thank goodness we've got the adults
back in the room kamala harris is new
communications director
though
i don't know he doesn't seem to be
exhibiting that kind of maturity and
responsibility jamal simmons he tweeted
out this was some years ago but he
tweeted out quote i worked for gore 2000
and believed bush's first term to have
been illegitimate
and he was making the point that you
should still stand in the room for
whoever's in the oval office even even
if you think it was a stolen election
but this guy believes kamala harris's
senior staffer communications director
believes that the 2000 election was
stolen
that bush wasn't the legitimate
president
can somebody please arrest this
insurrectionist
this threat to our precious sacred
democracy who is now he's going to be
working in our hallowed sacred temple of
democracy undermining it from the inside
just like the horn hat man who nearly
brought our empire to its knees
jamal simmons
the insurrectionist
no it's not just jamal simmons it's
terry mcauliffe he ran for governor of
virginia again he already was governor
of virginia he ran again and he just
lost to glenn young in this past cycle
he said during this campaign cycle that
he didn't think the 2000 election was
rightly decided and he thought that bush
was an illegitimate president
it's true that there are a number of
republicans who think that the 2020
election was stolen i don't know maybe
because they changed all the election
rules in the weeks before the election
but and because they violated the state
constitution in pennsylvania and there
were other irregularities but
the crazier statistic is that a higher
proportion of democrats believe the 2016
election was stolen
so
as we are now what day is it it's the
january 11th or five days after that
most sacred day of the liberal
liturgical year january january 6th the
day our country nearly came to its knees
spare me the sanctimony please don't
ever don't ever buy into it
don't ever give them quarter
and if you are inclined to be a squish
and say well you know it was really it
was so close the insurrectionists the
terrorists just don't just
move on just recognize when the left
says that the horn hat guy
was
nearly
toppled nearly toppled the entire
country or was an insurrectionist or a
terrorist or whatever
they don't mean it they're being
disingenuous they're doing the same
stuff themselves
we can just move on
according to the left we're all nazis
you know that we're all
fascist
white supremacist nazis
and this actually trended yesterday on
twitter because
according to the mainstream media
an indiana state senator
a republican in indiana
demanded that we be neutral on the
question of nazism this happened because
during a hearing some indiana school
teacher
whined to a state senator about a
curriculum reform bill
and he insisted that we
take on that imminent urgent scourge in
america
of nazism
we're not neutral on nazism we take a
stand in the classroom against it and it
matters that we do
i'm not discrediting as a person
marxism nazism fascism i'm not
discrediting any of those isms out there
and i have no problem with
the education system providing
instruction on the existence of those
isms
i believe that we've gone too far
when we take a position
on those isms as it relates to we need
to be impartial again i want to use this
term we need to be the purveyors of
reason we just provide the facts the
kids formulate their own viewpoints
okay i don't agree with his educational
theory but he's obviously not defending
nazism as the libs were accusing him of
doing that's so
disingenuous to say that he is
and that you have the school teacher
it's very important that we tell our
students that nazis are bad you know the
clay aiken thing do you think nazis are
bad yeah sure
say it again why
is there is that a really controversial
issue in america no you just want to
besmirch us all and smear us all as
nazis based on nothing but yeah sure
nazis are bad okay the schoolteacher
doesn't say that it's important that we
teach students that communists are bad
why not communists are really really bad
really really bad
nazi's bad sure communists really really
bad too they're really really they're
they're
certainly on the same level
but we're not allowed to say that we
have to say not the communists are good
nazis bad communists good multiple
people can be bad multiple ideas can be
really bad and communism is an evil evil
ideology so sure i agree with the school
teacher teach that nazism is bad
and teach that communism is evil too
oh but he doesn't want to do that
because that's the that's what's really
at issue here is that these curricula
are going really soft on communism and
in some cases actually encouraging
certain forms of marxism and what the
state senator who got in trouble did is
he came out there and he said look we
just need to be neutral we just need to
teach students how to think not what to
think we can't voice our own political
opinions and he took it to this radical
extreme where he said we have to be
neutral on
nazism
but i'm sure the teacher would agree
that we should be neutral on marxism i
bet the teacher wouldn't disagree with
that at all
it's just that nazism that that that
seems like a bridge too far and it and
of course it's a bridge too far
because the very idea that the state
senator is expressing is a liberal idea
it's the idea that when we educate
people we don't need to express moral
views
that's that's a liberal idea that they
smuggled into american education mostly
in the middle of the 20th century and
it's a bogus idea it's just not possible
you can't teach students how to think
without teaching them what to think
you can't teach them about history
without a moral framework to think about
history to think about which side was
right and for which reasons and at which
moments
to think about the philosophies that
were motivating these people
it's preposterous to say that we're
going to have an education system that
puts plato and aristotle at the same
level as the marquis de sade the man
from whom we get sadism yes you can read
plato's republic or you can read the
marquis de sade's pornography and the
things that are being described are
absolutely on the same level no they're
not or that's insane of course not
you have to have a moral
framework that's what education is
education is not just teaching you your
reading writing and arithmetic
education is raising someone up
teaching them to tamp down their basest
passions and appetites teaching them to
make sense of their freedom that's the
definition of liberal education and to
do that you need a moral viewpoint you
need to be able to say that some ideas
are evil and some ideas are good and
some movements were really bad and some
movements were good and you got to make
those decisions and the left has
benefited from this for
over half a century at this point
that's that's the issue here is when crt
is being taught in schools it's what
what they're teaching is that america is
bad and white supremacist and evil and
bigoted and there's structural racism
and we've got to tear it down and have a
new country
so the teachers actually write on the
broader point conservatives need to
listen to what the left is saying their
view of education is actually more
accurate than ours is how do we know
that because our view of education is
just the liberals pretend view that they
pushed us in the 60s and 70s that
they've now abandoned because it's
complete bunk
do you know who has a better idea on
education
governor ron desantis down in florida
governor desantis was just speaking with
mark levin and he described his new
proposal that the legislature is going
to take up this session to allow parents
to inspect the curricula that their kids
are being taught and to sue
the school districts if the schools are
peddling radical ideologies
they want these kids to hate this
country they want them to reject our
founding our institutions and they want
to replace that
with their leftist ideology which would
obviously be disastrous for this
country's future so the stakes are very
high on that but there's a problem when
you can say it you can't do it but what
if they defy you what if they're doing
it and so what we're going to be doing
in this upcoming legislative session
we're going to give parents the ability
to go in and get legal relief
if they're not following our state
standards with respect to history and
government and i think empowering
parents to be involved making sure
parents have a right to inspect the
curriculum and it's not just about
critical race theory i mean there's a
lot of other inappropriate content that
can be smuggled in
by
by public schools
but this is a threat to academic freedom
governor desantis oh no this is this is
totalitarian this is fascist you can't
tell teachers what they can teach
of course you can you have to that's
what curricula are that's why we have
public education because the public the
community is supposed to have some say
over how their kids are going to be
raised
the left already has this
well if we
permit this then conservatives can kick
certain books out of schools the left
already has that
you can read any book in school you can
read any book you want you can read
ibram candy you can read robin d'angelo
you could probably read mein kampf
there's one book that cannot be taught
in schools
what book is that's the bible
it's the most important book ever
written even if you don't believe in it
surely you would acknowledge that it is
central to western civilization
that's the one you can't teach in
schools
if if a teacher starts teaching the
bible in schools
that teacher will
have be punished the school will be sued
i promise you i guarantee you
furthermore if a teacher assigned my
book in schools well i guess either of
my books certainly reasons to vote for
democrats that would do it and
speechless too if they assigned
speechless they said hey speechless
controlling words controlling minds it's
a history of how words have changed
throughout
the last hundred years it's a history of
the left's manipulation of language from
the 1920s to 2020.
most of it's not particularly polemical
it's just a history of these ideas and
how it changed and what the left and the
right got wrong and right
i'd guarantee you that teacher would be
punished maybe the school would be sued
so what desantis is saying here is we're
not actually going to change the way
education is done in terms of the
form and the procedure
we're just going to allow conservatives
to do the same things that the left has
been doing for decades
so that we don't just completely roll
over and let the left take over our
culture and destroy and poison the
brains of future generations of
americans
sounds good to me sounds good to me man
sounds like this guy gets it
and that's why he's getting a lot of
hate right now there are a handful of
politicians who are getting a ton of
hate on the right
one or two senators
one really just one governor ron
desantis and trump of course
why
desantis knows why they're going after
him because he's right over the target
now look i mean when you're over the
target they're going to come at you but
what i view it as i view it as positive
feedback if the corporate press
nationally isn't attacking me then i'm
probably not doing my job so the fact
that they are attacking me is a good
indication that you know what i'm
tackling the big issues we're going
after critical race theory we're
fighting back against biden's mandates
we're fighting back against the illegal
immigration all those things that a vast
majority of floridians and americans
want to see done
but that does threaten uh the ruling
class in the regime and so when you
stand up in this day and age that we're
in when you're speaking the truth
those folks do not want that to get out
and so they are going to throw arrows at
you but i think that what we've been
able to show is if you stand your ground
if you lead if you don't back down and
just stand for the right things there's
a groundswell of folks who will have
your back and that ultimately is what
it's all about
listen to the language yes the point
he's making he's saying i'm doing a
really good job and that's why they're
attacking me
that's basically the argument he's
making
but listen to the language
the ruling class
the regime
standing for substantive things
this guy is not talking like republicans
talked five and 10 years ago or 20 or 30
years ago
this guy
is very dialed in this guy is using the
kind of language
that
we use on this show
that other
conservatives who i think are moving in
the right direction
that they're using they're recognizing
this is not just a battle between
republicans and democrats
or the conservatives and the leftists
but there's a structural issue here the
liberal establishment the ruling class
this it's not just private enterprise
versus big government it's the big
government and the administrative
agencies working with the woke
corporations and with the media and
working in tandem with the university
it's all kind of this it's just the it's
just the ruling class i don't know how
else you're going to describe it
i don't know who's writing his speeches
maybe it's desantis himself one thing i
can tell you though
expect to hear more of this as we get
closer to 2024
from the candidates who want to be taken
seriously
from the candidates who know
who know what time it is and who who
know what what time it's going to be
during the next presidential race subs
we're talking about substance not just
procedure not just you can say whatever
you want
and that's fine not just you can teach
whatever you want in schools
not just you can do whatever you want to
do just don't make me do it it's not
just that kind of
10 year old dated republican language
the kind of
fashionable libertarian kind of language
we're talking about substance standing
for the right things the right things in
the classroom the right things in our
community
the right things in our country
desantis is doing a good job on this
right now expect to hear more of this
from other candidates especially from
candidates who want to be taken
seriously in in the coming years both in
the midterms and presidential and moving
forward
speaking of florida
aoc
just took a little vacation to florida
kovid was exploding in new york
things are locked down still in many
ways so
aoc goes with her boyfriend they go to
florida
what happens
she's not wearing a mask
she's being a little loose with the
rules
she gets covered
i don't think she got covered because
she went to florida i don't think she
got covered because she's not wearing a
mask virtually all of my friends in new
york have covid right now or have
recently recovered from covid
but she got it
she's
extremely vaccinated she's one of the
biggest peddlers of all the covid
lockdown rules
she says
she her office sends out this statement
representative ocasio-cortez has
received a positive test result for
covid19 she's experiencing symptoms and
recovering at home the congresswoman
received her booster shot this fall and
encourages everyone to get their booster
and follow all cdc guidance
now the good news for the young healthy
aoc
is that
it doesn't matter it's like a cold
you'll be fine
but the political import here is that it
turns the consensus view on its head
the consensus view being peddled by the
establishment right now is that when
anti-vaxxers when anti-vaxx
anti-science
meaning people who don't just want to
stick themselves with some random drug
to prevent
or
or to not prevent getting a mild cough
that they're idiots they're they're
idiots they're rubes
actually though
it seems to me
that when someone who
goes out and says look we're all going
to get covet at some point it's just
promote for the vast majority of us it's
not going to be a big deal it's fine i'm
going to roll the dice
when that person gets covid that's
that's not ironic or funny or
that's what you would expect that's what
that person would expect too
it is much
much funnier
when a person who is triple vaxxed and
wears three masks at a time and locked
themselves in a hermetically sealed tube
for two years comes down with covid
because they thought they weren't going
to get it and they kept saying it's a
pandemic of the unvaccinated and they
believed fauci and rochelle wolenski and
joe biden
like idiots they believed these people
and then it turned out that what we were
told by wallensky and fauci and biden
just wasn't true
and then they got it that's
it's never funny when someone gets
a sickness you know thankfully in this
case
you know
the vast vast majority of people are
gonna be just completely fine some won't
even know that they have it
but if you're telling me one is funnier
than the other it is much funnier when
the people
have their expectations subverted and in
this case that would be
the left
but it would have been worse without the
booster
it would have been worse without the
vaccine that's what we're told maggie
haberman at the new york times and cnn
she tweets out
been avoiding this but
covet is the absolute pits been lucky it
isn't worse but at its worst it's like a
bad flu and it's dragged on and lingered
i'm vaxxed and boosted and still got a
breakthrough case man whole lot of
breakthrough cases going around huh gosh
golly i can't believe how many
breakthrough cases there are
would welcome folks not continuing to
say it's all mild
didn't you just say it's mild
you said it's like a bad flu it's fine
it's not no come on okay but don't say
it's mild
it would also have been much worse
without a vaccine and booster
like maybe
maybe i guess i'm not saying
i'm not saying that it definitely
wouldn't have been
much worse
but i i am saying that it would have
been worse without a vaccine and booster
is a cope for people who expected the
vaccines to work the way that we were
all told that they would work
and then they didn't work that way and
so now they're saying no but but it's oh
but thank goodness i got it because i
don't want to feel like an idiot for
believing those people and having been
completely wrong so look it would even
though it's completely unfalsifiable i
it would have been a lot worse
i know it i maybe maybe maybe it would
have sure it's possible but you'd
the only reason you believed that that
it would have been a lot worse without
the vax and the booster
is because you have been told that is
true by the same lying idiots who have
deceived you
on virtually every other aspect of the
virus
so why why would you believe that and
the craziest thing to me we were talking
yesterday about the potential mass
psychosis going on in this country
during kovid
is that people will now tell you with a
straight face
libs will tell when you point out that
the vaccines aren't doing what we were
told they would do
they will look you in the face and they
will say no michael the vaccines were
never supposed to prevent infection
michael the vaccines were never supposed
to stop stop transmission that's not
what we were told michael we were told
that they would just reduce the severity
of the symptoms
that's what vaccines do michael that's
why you get your polio vaccine to reduce
the severity of polio right
don't think so that's not what i
remember but you're hold on you're
telling me
that you really believe that we were
never told that the vaccines were going
to stop you from getting coveted
transmitting it
please
just go with me for a second let me take
you on a trip back down memory lane
there's been over a 20 to 1 return if
you had put that money into an s p 500
and reinvested the dividends you'd come
up with something like 17 billion
dollars but you think it's 200 billion
dollars here yeah you're okay you're not
gonna you're not going to get covet if
you have these vaccinations these
vaccines are highly highly effective
vaccinated people do not carry the virus
don't get sick they're really really
good against variants everyone who takes
the vaccine is not just protecting
themselves but reducing their
transmission
to other people and allowing society to
get back to normal get your first shot
and when you're due for your second get
your second shot a key goal is to stop
the transmission to get the immunity
levels up so that you get almost no
almost no
uh infection going on whatsoever when
people are vaccinated they can feel safe
that they are not going to get infected
they told you
the crazy part is not that they told you
this and then it turned out they were
completely wrong and either they're just
idiots or liars or more likely both the
craziest part as far as i'm concerned
is that you now believe
the lie that they're telling you
that the vaccines were never supposed to
stop infection or transmission
they j they just they're just telling
you no no ignore what you heard no don't
believe your lying eyes
no no oceania has always been at war
with east asia
no no oceania has always been at war
with eurasia
that
is
the kind of
mass psychosis that some people are
talking about right now
and sure maybe some of the things that
we are that are common sense views on
public health or public policy maybe
some of them are true but they're only
accidentally true and i don't think that
you should base your entire belief in
them on the utterances and whims and
caprices of the same
jerk
loser
incompetent
deceitful
liars who have misled us
for the past two years i'm michael
knowles the michael knowles show see you
more
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring our technical director is austin
stevens supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coramina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 22.
john bickley here daley wire
editor-in-chief wake up every morning
with our show morning wire on today's
episode the cdc changes its covet
messaging new york city allows
non-citizens to vote and pope francis
gets political
join us and get the facts first on the
news you need to know with our show
morning wire